it's still pretty impressive yeah all  these years later right  yeah with humble pine yeah we played  here in 69 or 70 we were opening for  Grand Funk Railroad and right here is  where my guitar was live and Jerry's  drum Jerry Shirley's drums were all  ready and so I just put out a big huge  ecord guitar and it just went and I  looked at journeyman and so then I did a  a G chord yeah same thing then I did an  a chord just to hear what all the  different and then I started there I  don't need no doctor right yeah and  Steve Merritt was at the mixing console  and he heard it he came running to the  stage jumped up didn't even pick a  guitar up and he said hold on the e  anyway I don't need no that's existing  about that yeah so that's where it  happened we've arranged it that  soundcheck yeah and did it that night  and did it ever every night after that  and that was the song that broke humble  pie right it was conceived right up here  that's such a great story